today nothing going on
here let's take a look at some uh some
experiments and then we're going to do
some stuff on GPU
Drive I think I'm just going to make a
GPU binding for puffer it's like the
puffer should have a GPU end binding
anyways so we're just going to make that
possible um that'll be way easier we'll
get some results it'll be
fun interesting
so this trained for longer it looks like
than before
oh yeah that actually did the full run
it was just faster than expected so
that's a 20 Bill
run can actually see that after a while
it's oscillating is a little weird that
the environments are synced up like
this I thought I'd broken this up but
um levels go
up Norm reward is low
but let's see level means are good
reward goes up and stays up it's a
little oscillatory but it's
good I don't know if we have
the smoothing enhancements on this yet
we should look at
that uh I think we probably don't is why
this isn't so nice reward
distance okay this is a little sketchy
that it goes up and then back
um yeah this is sketchy here for sure
this should be straight
up so my guess is that it was actually
doing well until right here so it did
very well for like two billion steps and
then crashed as my guess I'm seeing all
this skill usage
here oh wait this is just the burst
movement though hm
interesting Well we'd have to see what
they actually ended up doing do we have
entropy
crash no interestingly entropy goes back
up value loss is
insane definitely value so value loss
blew up you can see right
here we'll have to do something about
that that looks like hyper pram screw up
or something
thing which makes sense um we have a
really really dumb setting right now for
Value function clipping and stuff which
I don't know the hyper pram thing we
need ELO as a as an optimization metric
but hey we can run uh we can do full
runs now we've fixed that environment
bug this is pretty
good and was there anything
else I think we
had we had like one other thing to look
at right before GPU Drive
maybe
this yeah cqu
Quest all right we have a reasonable
train curve for cqu Quest as well these
look quite
nice so we've got pretty much good hyper
pram sweeps on
everything um I am a little bit curious
as to
why with so many any of these it doesn't
choose to do longer
runs you know it has the option to do
longer runs but it doesn't do
it well no big deal in any event let's
um let's get on GPU
drive so
let's
do a couple
things
so first of all we're going to fix the
the stuff I broke
yesterday not going to do
this going to break some stuff
now what we're going to do is we're
going to go look at the
it I think what we're going to have to
do is we're going to just have to accept
that this is going to be a GPU
environment and we're going to make a
GPU binding and if we can come up with a
way to do CPU binding later we'll do
it um I think my drona needs to be
compiled with
okay so this is the one thing that I do
potentially
need is this
EnV and everything else I don't really
need so we'll do stash
Madrona how do we compile Madrona with
GPU support let's see
I don't see anything on Madrona compile
here except maybe
this external
uh this is just
their
sample Cuda I have this
dependencies are needed I think WSL
should work
right it's possible this just doesn't
work in
um let's like commit some stuff up on
puffer and let's get this set up on the
bigger puffer box because I don't want
to be fighting compilation errors and
stuff if it's just going to be because
of my local setup
so which box do I use for
this I think actually is it puffer box
one let's use puffer box
one make sure this is clear yep we're
good this was just being used for
did I fork it
actually let me Fork it while I just
have
that'll make it easier if we need to PR
anything right
Loops good news
is uh this is actually way faster
because it's now this is
running on the puffer box which is
connected to better
and we'll do this manual install and
then while this is running we'll uh
we'll handle some other
stuff and this should compile with
proper GPU
support we'll run some tests
we'll run some
tests this will also be the first time
we'll be adding a GPU environment
binding to puffer which like really
puffer is not going to be able to do
very much um other than like do some
hygiene and maybe like some some decent
Integrations so you're not really
getting the full benefit of the puffer
stack with this but hey you know it's a
cool environment so we have at least
some tools that they'll uh they'll find
useful I'm
Branch set up
Vector and clean puff
forl we also need to add where is it
environment's GPU Drive
environment
torch and
any
uh yeah let's do this as well
okay so that's actually perfect timing
for us now we have this
compiled and pip install d e
dot
yes oh it just it just C us to build
we're good
installed pull this
down we would also like to have this
test GPU drive
file
um we probably don't need that
though we we won't need it
so the main thing that we're going to
have to figure out
is we're going to have to figure out how
we want to pass uh Cuda
tensor
around I don't think that's
terribly
difficult we're just going to have to
add a couple things to clean puffer ale
I think which is like it's fine I try
not to blow up that file
but I think like adding a it's like a
couple if statements it's really not a
lot
um whoops hate when I actually
accidentally get into tree
mode
um okay so this gets changed to
Cuda right
and we don't need numai
now so
is we're not using this yet it's going
to end up having to be a torch
tensor um we don't need this to be like
this we just need action equals action.
view like this
that
Dynamics don't need any of this just
going to be
worlds Zer like
do2 uh terminal. device we'll do that
and this will be slow
so let make
it yeah this isn't supposed to be
hard um so now that we have
this environment
I'm trying to think how I want to add
this I think all I have to
[Music]
do cuz technically this is going to get
wrapped in uh a cereal at the moment and
that'll screw it up right
directly I think what I should do is I
should just make
I should make a new VC backend that is
native and the native back end will just
take whatever data you have and passed
it
do it has to have the same signature
like this
okay and
then
en hurry
up get it
done will have you ever had [ __ ] break
because of
multiprocessing start method for 5
hours
and uh unable to have CPU mode execution
not take up all your cores and a million
other cursed
things [ __ ] Madrona gave me a hell of
a day
yesterday all
Madrona so I'm adding GPU binding to
this which is not going to be able to
take advantage of all of puffer's
features but at the least we're going to
be able to get uh you know some fast
training and we'll be able to do some
hyper pram sweeps and stuff because I'm
not dealing with this unless Madrona has
a fix for it um because their default
multiprocessing is too
slow we had a problem at open a this one
time
could have given me a
call I deal with in for hell all day
man four days of Dev
time yeah I remember that they were
using
um they're they were using for
vectorization they were just using like
raw MPI and it was just the worst
garbage code I'd ever seen it was it was
bad um it was just like process
conditional logic with no debugging
whatsoever and no error messages it was
terrible yeah that
was that was
rough there is a better way you know you
can just write multiprocessing
jeez GDB was like Greg is so freaking
cool though he was I remember he would
just be coding with the DOTA Team all
day he had like uh like a lazy boy type
chair pulled up and he'd just be there
just like like reclined and just like
working on hard in for [ __ ] with the
DOTA team it was awesome
I hope he's doing well I have uh no idea
what the heck is happening at open AI
right
now but
uh having no Insider knowledge
whatsoever I'm guessing he's probably
just actually taking a vacation because
the guy's been working for nine years
and probably like Schulman and a few of
the other researchers have gotten sick
of doing too much product side stuff
because it's like hard to do science
when stuff scales so much that would be
my guess but I don't
know I don't think that they've secretly
solved
everything I doubt
it other thoughts on yeah yeah I spoke
with shman a few
times I don't think we saw eye to eye on
everything just mostly because he is
much more um you know he's much more
scientifically minded I'm much more
engineering
minded though I actually I started out
when I was uh starting off I was way
more on the science side than I am now
like I trended towards the engineering
side just because like it was the thing
that let me actually build stuff and get
things done and and like I didn't see
any way to push forward on the science
when all of the Tooling in RL was so
broken that you were like you were
getting results on things that like
could not be known to be useful it was
rough I will say I uh bunch of schan
papers are like the actual ones that I
keep referring to on stuff I keep
finding like really bad fuckups in
everybody else's papers but uh so far
has been good on
that his uh his single agent he's on the
single agent scaling paper
right yeah yeah so this paper
here man this is like
this is such an important
paper I'm not going to my DMs
live relax I have two monitors anyways
but uh this paper is so
important that like cuz this paper
basically confirms everything that I
thought about RL that it's like a data
scaling thing not a parameter scaling
thing
I see thanks for the DM will yeah that
that makes
sense
yeah we'll talk about that elsewhere but
um yeah the like the fact that RL scales
with data is good I got to start my
stupid stream for web dev with Claud
slop I need you to speed up your Dev
speed
sir look it's you either write stuff
slow and you get it done right or you
write slop okay you want a cool demo
here I think I can do uh
breakout mode uh RB does this work eval
demo here okay so I made a play test
where you can play this is me playing uh
you can play it the way that the agent
sees it this is how the agent sees and
plays montazuma Revenge it's really hard
because of frame Skip and stuff and then
I made it you can do this with any any
game any Atari game and then you can set
this to render mode human and you can
play the game the way that humans are
supposed to play the thing and you'll
see that it's still ridiculously hard
but substantially
easier so pretty much if anybody had
bothered to do this like years ago we
wouldn't have been making stuff so hard
with Mont Zuma's Revenge this game is
like ridiculously hard I'm actually
surprised I haven't died yet yeah there
you
go and it's like freaking impossible
with uh with frame skip as
legitimately but you can get a few
hundred points and I think think RL can
get a few hundred points just
fine so there you go works with any of
the
thing I also did a run of 20 billion
steps on the MOBA overnight and I can
tell you for sure that the hyper prams
are
bad argument is that frame skip is you
don't need real reaction
time uh it's it's still an impairment
because of how precise um how precise
the game is it's like a legit Precision
platformer and uh oh yeah sticky actions
forget it sticky actions totally screw
stuff up and actually I found that it's
even like people were like riging on me
for um doing a click like click baiting
with the title like all all of RL is
broken no it's even worse than I thought
I just said it was the default in Al Pi
but actually as of like v5.0 a lot of
the v5.0 gymnas M M's have sticky
actions by default as well so it's even
worse frame skip is fine okay frame skip
is totally fine to speed stuff up but
here's the thing you sweep it as a
hyperparameter you don't fix it so you
put it into your carb sweep or your
whatever as a hyper pram and then you go
based on reward versus wall clock time
and then it's done right it's that easy
so that's what I've been doing with all
these sweeps is I have uh I have frame
skip as a hyper param it's not fixed and
that makes it really really easy because
I can just go down here and I can see
look these are the runs that it's chosen
five frame skip four frame skip three
frame Skip and it doesn't have anything
below
that and this is uh sequ
overnight so this type of stuff is going
to be really nice for
RL frame skip is really a part of the
agent code people didn't want to change
the
N yeah that's the thing is they didn't
play the M if they uh if they played the
M they would
have yeah it well this comes from me not
caring about Academia right if you're in
the mindset of like I don't want to have
to convince reviewers that this is the
right way to do it you're going to make
bad decisions right I no longer care I'm
not writing papers I'm solving [ __ ] so
it actually like as soon as that like
switch flips everything started getting
I think this Nerfs like this Nerfs paper
cycle the reviews will be back in two
days for a data sets and benchmarks and
then legitimately I think this is going
to be my last conference cycle like
unless I have something that's just
super easy to write up uh I probably
just won't submit anything
else this is why open ey exceeded
Academia yeah it was really
good it was really
good and the thing is you do end up
convincing people as well because like
you get this result right and it's like
hey we can kind of just hyperparameter
tune whatever and like I don't need
anything fancy it just wins right and
it's
fast you kind of like you have to exceed
by a huge margin but once you're getting
these results that are just so so good
like that's when people buy
it LM papers LM papers
did you train your foundation model from
scratch yeah
ridiculous this one was cool you can see
like it like actually latching on to uh
finding like the good hyper parameter
Zone like
this all right see
you thanks for dropping by
will only Twitter are you on Twitter I'm
on I'm on YouTube and twitch right now
as
solid yeah the YouTube audience is way
better cuz uh of my thesis video mostly
I actually get decent viewership from
there quite often
um has anyone du carbs for neural
architecture they kind of did in the
original carbs they at least swept the
network sizes so that's actually one of
the things I'm going to do next is I'm
going to add like some Network size
parameters into carbs but um you it
carbs is not purely magic right like the
more stuff that you add into it um the
bigger the search space gets it can't
just like magically do gigantic hyper
pram spaces so I think once I like cut
down some of these ones that are
basically never need to be messed with
um then I can add like a few scaling
parameters
in that gets to be substantially more
compute though and uh I don't know I I
am planning on building out the puffer
cluster hopefully relatively soon that's
going to have to be post Revenue um but
for now I like the current cluster got
to bunch of issues I have to RMA some
boxes because of the stupid Intel CPU uh
cluster [ __ ] that's
happened in any case you should make a
neural AR what do you mean a neural
architecture search rln you can do it on
any environment
right you can just use any environment
that's fast and then do neural
architecture search on it right
you're either about to say something
that's genius or makes no sense
oh you're not going to use carbs to
train a generator Network that's not
going to
happen that's too many parameters
I don't even know how much benefit you
get out of architecture search these
days
like okay eventually I see H
maybe we'll see how much benefit there
is actually to architectures in general
versus just Computing data scaling
I think like you might end up doing
pretty well just by getting some basic
building blocks right we still don't
even have a good way to do Transformers
and reinforcement
learning like not whatsoever not even
[Music]
close they're just way too slow
architect studying grocking has
shown architectural
limitations yeah but you still have to
be able to parameterize this space right
like most neural architecture search is
pretty restricted
[ __ ] what you've got way too many papers
oh I saw this
thing maybe I've just spent too much
time in reinforcement learning but
like my opinion of scientific papers in
general this these days is that that
they're wrong until proven right by test
of time
maybe I've just spent too much time in
reinforcement
learning I don't know how often is it
that like LM papers are just
wrong cuz in RL it feels like it feels
like you're just throwing darts like the
majority of RL papers that are published
at nurs even like spotlights and stuff
are just
wrong and they're like trivially
provably wrong as well
ban freaking twitch
Bots uh neural architecture search
Stills a place and we can either do
graduate student descent or do neural
architecture search and recent results
suggest that architecture matter yeah
quite Poss possibly quite Poss I think
that this will get easier
like the problem is we need better like
well if we're going to do this we need
way better compilation and stuff because
um for RL like the models are tiny and
they need to launch fast so like that
we're getting really limited by having
shitty kernels for Stuff um it's one of
the reasons I write such simple
architectures is like you end up just
getting screwed by like kernel launch
times and stuff when the models are so
small so like you could do this but it
would have to it would almost have to
just generate a monolithic fuse kernel
for the whole
thing like even torch compile like the
freaking launch overhead is just brutal
you okay we go back to oh welcome
YouTube
folks we're going to add today we're
adding a
native vectorization method that's going
to
support actually it's going to support a
few things um but the main use case is
going to be GPU
environments uh the native vectorization
is just going to say that your
environment is already in the right
format so puffer is basically just going
to do a pass
through and allow you to use the GPU
environment with the rest of our
this and then I need to Def find async
reset
send receive and
nice job super
Maven
um do you even set the the flag like
that in async yeah you
do so all we will do
is
um dot ready
Ms equals
start
reset so this is not actually async but
it doesn't return anything it matches
the function
here uh I don't know how I got into this
serial
code that's
weird Okay do this here it's
reset uh
so
do ready
and death
receive okay a few API things we have to
do few API
things this thing is supposed to be able
to
close
yeah okay it needs to return
everything need to return
everything it's a little bit difficult
actually cuz I need to know the native
data types
oh I know what I'll do that's fine we'll
just assume that they return like that
we'll just make them we'll just put the
onus on the environment to do
it yeah that's way easier and then in
that case this is literally done this is
all that this needs to be and then all I
have to do is edit the GPU Drive
environment a little bit
so so we'll do back is going to be
choices
native
this and then in GPU
drive we will allocate some
buffers so we'll just
do
dot
reward.
zeros reward terminal
truncated
fine
OBS s. reward terminal truncated okay so
this is going to be the vector
API and this is not a puff M now right
yeah this is not a puffer n so to do not
a puffer
n here's some API
Shenanigans Let's ignore API Shenanigans
now because API Shenanigans is stupid
and
boring
um OBS terminal tunet INF okay this is
good this is
good and
truncated can be self do
no config for M
name okay I forgot to commit it no big
deal
cool got our
[Music]
config no module ooh
worked is there a Sim link or something
I forgot
I think that this has to be after
the the change dur right so can I just
put this here
assertion
error that's
fine uh
config so what we're going to do is
we're going to tell this to use one
m one
worker and uh all this is going to do
basically is just like make the gpn
handle its own
something no module Pi GPU Drive how do
I get this working locally
I did make a Sim
link okay that's
good and then we know that
error VI
Drive
move
build
now for some reason even though
build now for some reason even though I'm on python 11 this compiles as python
I'm on python 11 this compiles as python
10 you just just rename it and it
imageio M torch
M oh that's obnoxious that you need
image
iio no big deal though P game no module
named P game okay those things should
not be being imported like that
support that's weird because it should
be
I don't see anything that would
be I don't see anything that would prevent this from compiling with Cuda
[Music]
jeez I actually remember this being a
thing with
Madrona is it not working with uh with
old
cake I thought i' put this into the
docker actually
docker so the thing that's going on here
is like this is one of the Annoying
curse things with RL is like they're
annoying dependencies
and this is what puffer tank is for I
suffer once and then I put everything
into the docker and nobody has to suffer
again
here I could have
sworn we
let me find this because I remember
fixing this exact issue before with
Aaron who was using it for a different
project and I could have sworn that he
sent me the
um yep I found it
so app get
update and then we're going
to install a couple of
[Music]
things install W get lib
okay so now we've got
cake te
make and then we do
and then the hope is that this gets us a
cmake that will actually work to compile
Madrona with GPU build support and then
we'll be able to get this working and
then what I'll do is then I will just
like once we have this project nice and
working in order to distribute it more
easily for everybody I'll just update
the puffer tank base to have this nice
new cmake on it as well as some other
hygiene stuff P torch 2.4 not a Dev
build stuff like that and we'll go from
linky as linky
says if uh you haven't started the
repository yet and you find any of my
work interesting or
useful start the puffer not this one um
Puffer
here
so this will take a quick second I think
that this was all that was needed though
if I recall cuz I'm pretty sure I we
debugged this exact same problem before
and it was just straight up
co-pilot I think I'm trying to remember
if I have
that I have um I've been using super
Maven these days it's been way nicer
done maybe not anyways though this will
finish we'll compile
um what am I doing today yeah I probably
should have started the stream with that
shouldn't I have
um so there's this GPU
Drive see simulator that was released
yesterday I was hoping to have Day One
support but it took me a little longer
than
expected it's an ultra high performance
GPU accelerated driving
simulator and we're adding it to puffer
at the moment now yesterday I wasted a
lot of time I was trying to get it to
work in CPU mode because puffer has
optimization such that that can actually
be faster um but we ran into just a lot
of lowlevel
[ __ ] and ended up just just having a
really rough day of it yesterday so
today uh instead we're going to just
make a GPU binding this will be puffer's
first GPU bound environment we're going
to make a little API for it and then
we're going to ship it and hopefully by
the end of today we'll actually have
like experiments running on this thing
and automatically tuning itself to bit
get better and better at driving which
will be fun
seake people have been asking me to do
this for a while anyways
practically speaking this will be very
simple to
do
okay I think we got
cake there we go that's correct cake
version
I think you need to like close an open
shell or
whatever and what we're doing here now
is we're going to do the manual
install
recompilation and hopefully this
actually compiles the GPU support for
okay now we see whether this actually
worked the way we expected it
too really madona was not compiled with
GP with Cuda support how is that
possible we literally just compiled
clean why is this not compil with GPU
support do I have to go into Mone it and
compile it there
compilation I should have like warnings
about GPU shouldn't I
let me
see
so compiles with some
warnings could not find
doxygen including X11 support
my droner was not compiled with Cuda
support what the
I'm trying to think what the hell else I
had to do to get Cuda support working
I'm trying to think if this is likely to
be
oh interesting that's
weird
nice seake is actually picking up the oh
okay
wait maybe it's
variable
python version for
cake
D is it d python executable
on okay
so can I do
this is the exact
error that I
I'm trying to figure out what I do for
this
compiler I don't know how you get it to
use a specific version of
python really obnoxious
I I think I have to do it like this
right
slash it's not user local where's my
freaking python user bin
that ought to be good
right
cake okay we go to
build does this do
it d python
libraries it exe is it executable or
libraries
know oh wait I have an idea as to what
might be happening
though yep okay so what's happening is I
was I think here copy GPU Drive
I think I was rebuilding it but it was
to the long the wrong
location uh n is going to
be mode
[Music]
train still no
well this is not even the issue
maybe let me just make sure cuz I think
it's probably cashing some
oh okay this is interesting
right could not include
recursive
okay what is all this
for this is a high performance GPU
driving Sim I'm trying to add support
for I add it to
puffer so we can train some cool models
for
okay so that does compile
oh wait no I just cloned it what am I
talking
about one step
ahead y see if it
compiles okay something
happens the thing that's not working at
the moment is Madrona which is the
underlying engine that this uses is for
some reason is not compiling with GPU
support
what the hell it's still not not compile
with Cuda support that's
insane
um I honestly don't know then
um I guess I'm going to get it working
with CPU mode then first and then figure
that out later in the day because I
don't know otherwise what the heck I
can't get this thing compiling with the
with GPU support
do device equals
CPU
then okay that error we do know how to
fix
GPU
[Music]
and
forch so there's this one hot right
here no it's on the road off objects
isn't
it I think right
here and we
have where did I put
wanted very
good
now NV ID
mask
right so we have to add a couple things
to puffer lib
V ID
now self.
n oops not this
one right
here so let's just do self do
D OBS rewards
DS ter truncated
infos mid
mask and what was the data type of self
mask is this an
array or a list I think it's probably an
Umpire
exactly
mask let's do
that and then we'll just
return invalid tensor shape that's fine
we we messed with the
model we will unmess with the model
now let's unmess with the model
we don't need this stupid
thing still inv valid input tensor shape
okay where
interesting before we even get
there
here just forgot to change a couple
things back we're
good probability
tensor INF Nan or element less than zero
o okay
um I thought we'd masked
this I thought we had masked
this I'm going to go use the restroom
turn the fix the AC be back in a minute
we'll keep
okay we got a lot of stuff we can work
on with this
today um I think that the smartest thing
is going to just be to get the end to
end working and the end to end working
and then we'll figure out the GPU
[ __ ]
so for. max
OBS okay it does have nans in it
does have nans in
it which is very
oops let's look for the mask that we
made and we're going to actually what
we're going to do is we're going to just
make this mask way earlier so what we're
going to
is I'm going what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take
we'll just
do States
yeah we're just going to do on all of
these so we don't have to deal with
it wait torch.
tensor that's funny how that works um
it well why the heck is there giant
observation in
there that's weird
that's going to crash
everything okay
so where
OBS I guess we just put a break point
and just see where we're getting nans
yeah there is not the normalization on
this still oh well that we're going to
normalize after right so if I just do
like
this for. Max
ego yeah perfect okay so this
works let's do partner
[Music]
obervations
um max
OBS perfect negative 1 to negative 0.5
to
one now we actually have some clean
data hopefully we can do something with
this
uh
of Nay because this is going to be a
umpire array
right yeah so it is actually torched
from
numpy perfect we got it training
very
cool
and 3 Two
Worlds and this be made
slower okay
um let me send a couple messages
is let me see how my DMs if I have any
DMS on
some
reason for
this in the meantime in the meantime let
us check we had we had a dock somewhere
so algorithms sp3 call back is where
they do logging
evidently it's interesting that they use
a
deck I see why you would do that that's
kind of funny
I see
so H there's a info
dick I
see a lot of
code uh
create and log
videos I generally don't log videos to w
b just because they take a ton of memory
and they're kind of slow to
okay so let's
grab let's grab these and let's start
making
some metrics unless I have an
instance NOP no replies yet so let's
start on
what I usually do with this is I Define
like a report
interval let's say I make it 32 steps
right and
then I'll do
H I don't know if I want to log these
every
so when I do like
infos right don't I have something for
this where's my logging I know I have
logging somewhere
levels
yeah so I just I I don't accumulate so
that's
fine um self. report
interval and then what we do in
step
if we need to add a tick as well
tick
zero do this on
reset s. tick plus equals 1 and this
this is wrong it's going to be
if self. tick percent report
interval is equal to
zero we do info equals s.m. get
info and
and info
num agent num was it
finished agents
oh wait is that
it actually there just might I might
just be
done we'll just see what's in
here if I'm just going to get the dick
okay does this have info
dict is info
is it info tensor maybe is that what it
has to be
want oh I think that
they this info dick just like
manually do they just make
this and info dim
okay so there's a bunch of stuff in this
okay I can see right
here they actually
have off-road vehicle collisions SCH
okay so they actually just make this on
wait self. m.g
infos is there get
and they do this on okay I see that they
do it this way which is probably what we
want to do they do it on episode so we
have to basically do what they did in
this rapper this code is good um this is
like a rare case where they they
actually did a really like they did
actually wrote really good stuff here
and there's actually not much for me to
do other than just write a binding um
unless we get CPU mode working then it
would be substantially easier
lots of cool
stuff okay
right instead of report interval yeah we
literally just do end of episode
reporting which is going to make it a
little tricky when we do um if we do CPU
Port but it's okay for
now
be
well self
okay if done
worlds
any items
there's a dead agent mask thing but then
there's also the info update
so
ex self
dot.
reset world idx is equal to
idx and then we have to update the info
tensor
okay
indices select info for controlled
agents
so what we'll do
is done
worlds
info
Road
equals infot
tensor do
sum. item
info vehicle let me scroll this so you
can see
it
collisions
info goal
a
achieved and
then
info numb
finished
okay and
then we have mean reward per
episode tote
reward how do we get tote reward per
episode
[Music]
fact and on
step we do self.
episode turns plus equal to reward
looks torch. wear okay let's see what's
wrong with
see so you have to do this before the
reshape I
I think we're going to store the uh the
rewards the returns like this and then
the way that we're going to get
around this is we're going to do hey
Noah we had uh we had some trouble with
this environment yesterday I'm uh this
is day two I'm really going to try to
get the binding for this done then
hopefully we'll be back to the rest of
this stuff how's breakout going
I don't know if you saw this yesterday
this is the GPU driving
Sim okay we did get to our break
point but this one's not particularly
useful Becca is done
agent is not learning
anymore it's just going do the rewards
make
sense a very easy test is if you just
play the game yourself and print out the
rewards as you're playing it on every
tick see if they make
items reward is just the current
score well that's not that's a bad
reward
function it should be one the reward
should be like one every time you break
a block it should not be the current
score that's a really really bad reward
function
why is that
bad nope because here's the
thing the first of all there's the
scaling of the reward your reward now
goes over many orders of magnitude which
is bad second of
all um if you think about it like now
your reward is like if you're at score
100 and you get to 101 that's a very
small difference in score from one time
step to the next and third of all the
value function also now has to learn to
predict the score so it has to learn to
like read the scoreboard in order to be
able to tell unless you have a wrapper
in there creates all sorts of
difficulties for the
algorithm you definitely do not want
that reward function you definitely it's
good to have like a nice continuous
reward function but the thing you have
done is not actually a continuous reward
function you've like you've not given it
any additional information over uh
giving it a one every time it gets a
block and you've poorly condition the
reward in the process change it to one
it'll
work give the agent yeah that shouldn't
take you very long long you just set
reward to zero and then if it breaks a
block you set it like plus
one do that retrain it it probably just
learns
instantly I mean I literally have a
sweep of uh the other Breakout game like
the original breakout on puffer and it
I'm hoping we can get this down to a
like we can get it so that it's very
nice and consistent and easy to
implement a bunch of these and maybe we
can Implement you know like maybe we'll
do like the original Seven Atari games
so we'll have like seven fast Atari
games for puffer or something that might
be
fun Ultra fast but the key is they have
to be they've got to be like the full
game right like there's like Min minari
or whatever from ja like we're not we
got to do the full games we don't want
strip down versions of the games right
yours is
good like if I were to do pong for
instance I would actually have to do the
pong physics because there's actually
like some kind of intricate acceleration
in there stuff like that
fine maybe controlled agent mask is the
wrong
is it do item instead of do
items I'm dumb it's just do
item broke my
terminal good job
uh okay so this seems to be
working how about this now
[Music]
m. reset World
idx reset
got
reset maybe the uh self
reset is not what I think it
is uh here it is itself.
m. sim. reset
NOP where is
it s.m. sim.
reset
world or just
do you need to get the info before you
reset it
though
wait wouldn't you need to yeah you need
to get the info before you reset
it oh which I
do look at
that that's nice
so my info should be returning shouldn't
they
do we get
here no
what oh
it needs to be a
nonsense um well you have part of it
right in that it is a lot of
nonsense you definitely have that
correct so I give
you full marks for
difference do I have any
messages the question
all
right let's go figure out
GitHub oh we didn't even check this one
now they never
replied how about our GPU Drive
issue actually I kind of want that tab
that one's annoying to
well we got a
nice we got a good reply
here me click a few
things so from here we have a few
options I think we want to get the masks
working next which will unfortunately
Drive perf down a fair bit um but you
know it'll come back once we get the GPU
Excel and then some
give it us some
garbage do our
have we can just do self. controlled
agent mask right
let me see how they do the their live
agent
mask on the
here we go so I want to figure out how
they're doing their
masking the idea here is that uh agents
can die the cars can crash or they can
achieve their goal either way they'll be
removed from
play and there is some masking that has
to be
done in order to accomplish that
so we right
here dead agent
mask let's see they initialize it up
here inside of
that's
fine and then what they do
is they use this as a mask everywhere
cool and then they logical ore right
here and yeah this is what I
was right here this is they need to
reset it
okay so it's basically the code that I
expected Let's uh let's add this
ourselves so self-controlled agent
mask is
here and then in reset we'll do live
agent
mask
self. controlled agent mask.
clone and do they use for logging do
they use the live ones or what do they
use they use the controlled mask for
some
reason so we'll keep that
there and then on
step they update it
somewhere they update it after
logging so they'll
do self.
there and then now down here in step we
do
mask they do it before
resetting yeah they do
this I think I can technically do this
up here though if I just do it up
here so I just set the mask of terminal
to be false
so you can no longer
see the dead
agents and then here in
reset we have to do
well that's somewhat obnoxious that we
can't
yeah
um I guess I can
just it's slightly annoying that I have
to have the mask be flat like
this but I can probably just do
self. trolled agent mask of
num
um
x this is mask not control controlled
agent
mask I think that's
good now the other thing I could do that
would be
cleaner I could
do agent
mask and then self. mask equals
without the Clone this is a nice trick
actually I use this all over in my scon
code so this will be useful for people
so you make right here you make uh this
copy of the mask and now this is not a
copy this is a
view so we have a structured one and we
have a flat
one and what that means is I can go up
here
and I can do self. live agent
terminal is equal to zero this is the
structured
one and then I can go down here and I
can do self. live agent mask and I don't
need any of this logic anymore I just
need
idx this is substantially
cleaner I no longer have to do this
look how nice that is and we return
self. mask which is the flat one it's a
nice
trick tensors used as indices must
be of a specific data
type
subtraction with a bull
operator there's code that I didn't
write I did not write this
code cannot convert float
Infinity to
says okay so we have some agents
right then
reset and we
return we return reasonable stuff don't
we
I'm assuming that this is
because Global step is zero right
Ray I don't know why why it doesn't know
the API for
this see
this
uh it is impossible that the steps per
second is the same as before
though so that's an
yeah look at that data density less than
10% is actual
data most of it's just
padding oh hello YouTube folks
welcome we're making some progress on
this uh for folks who just got here this
is the GPU Drive environment from
Eugene's group at
NYU um it is a high performance GPU
Simulator for driving we're currently
attempting to add support in puffer I
keep running into all sorts of lowl
issues this is the first GPU accelerated
environment I'm adding to puffer I tried
to actually add a CPU version of this
but I ran into issues uh puffer's whole
stack is really optimized for CPU but
know nowadays we actually do have a fair
number of nice general purpose tools so
I thought that it would be good to add
in anyways so today the goal is to have
some sort of reasonable binding for this
and to have some automated experiments
uh running that will find us good
policies for driving with like nicely
tracked metrics and all of puffer's uh
quality of life Stuff Plus carbs
hyperparameter sweeps so we do have that
nice hyperparameter
integration and we're going to see how
well it does uh we have a few issues
that we're kind of going back and forth
on
here they've been pretty good on
replies I mean I really haven't had many
big issues with this project
specifically the main issues have just
been from the underlying madona engine
that they use being a total
pain but you know we'll uh we will get
there no
worries okay so the next thing I need to
figure out
is
why uh the global step
up the fact it goes up that high is
weird
right the reason that it's fast is
because it's saying that we have good
data
density but that can't possibly be the
case uh I probably just orked
the the reset call
right CU this should actually be hurting
yeah yeah right here so this live agent
mask is wrong this is self. controlled
agent mask of
yeah okay now we get something way more
reasonable right here you can see that
that agents die agents spawn back in but
it stays in the range of like the
original data
steps unfortunately it also means it's
going to be incredibly
inefficient but they have told me that
there are ways to make the simulator
return better quality
data we might have have to reduce the
batch size a
lot yeah all the way from 60,000 steps
per second down to
2,000 steps per
environment um we could try to do some
hyper pram sweeps but this is so
ridiculously
slow we could try with very small batch
sizes I guess and just hope that the Sim
is not that hard to
solve I think I'd like to let's see if
we can at least do some level of
optimization here I should be able to
get I think I should be able to get a
free like 4X
Improvement maybe 8x
let me
open I have like DMS on
this where's my window
50,000 so I'm going to just tell them
the
okay cool lots of support from the team
that's awesome to see not going to show
the DMS but
um yeah very
nice yeah I uh I see that they say I
probably have some bugs which is
expected this is a Brand New Port I can
show this
so looks like may be a bug since they
have a value of
8.0 I think it's a sum instead of a mean
or something like that
that should be them adding me to the
slack so that they can help with the uh
the coed bugs and then we should be well
on our way
we should be well of on our way let me
go grab my my work email hold
on and then I will just basically be
while I'm deving this I'll be on the
side chatting back and forth seeing if I
can get the Cuda stuff
is
continue joining their slack and
hopefully they will help us get Cuda
support uh for the environment
channels you actually have to upgrade in
order to
freaking that's
obnoxious I mean I'll I'll do that if I
need
to slack is such garbage where
that's
fine I'm sure I'll forget to cancel this
forever but
unironically I just want all the
freaking stuff to just be done on
Discord that'll be funny oh yeah join
the
Discord So the plan for this is once we
get um once we sort of we'll go back and
forth on Cuda and um once we
have that uh we will be able to get this
running a little faster but in the
meantime sort of while I'm messaging
here back and forth unless we get going
on that too much uh I'm going to try to
optimize the data density a little bit
because they have literally they have
the identical problem that I ran into
for years with neural MMO and it's a
killer like it will actually kill all of
your research because it just makes it
too slow to be usable um so they say
that their Sim runs at a million plus
but they only train at 50k we need to
get them training at several 100k
application does anybody actually like
slack that uses
it I remember it used to not be bad and
it's just gotten worse and
worse I guess the same is true for a lot
of stuff Discord used to be better as
heaven forbid somebody hack my open
source research channels
holy hell the amount of stuff that they
make you do in order to just use their
bad
software is
there we
go
yay I actually can do this now I I'm
intentionally on the side screen here
just because
cool while we're doing that let me pull
up the notes that I got from uh from
Daphne
on how to make this thing faster
so says to set road map OBS
false K Max observation count
points oh wait that's just observation
size
we want to
add we want to make the simulator return
us less dense data
so I was told that if you just go into
this GPU
Drive uh it should be in
consts HPP but I tried messing with this
before for
cool is that Pablo wait I don't like it
neither do I use
it okay I thought that was different
Pablo maybe it is
um unfortunately slack is one of those
things that just crops up repeatedly
where like you you're essentially forced
to use it because somebody's going to
need to use it it's fine though it works
for now uh where's the slack so I can
make sure I keep that window open at
least okay now I was told to reduce this
kmax agent count thing
here so if I like reduce this to
32 and then I was also to told to
do uh to reduce this
potentially so let's do this to
64 this is good
okay let's see if this gives me the same
data shapes as
before good
this gives me different data
shapes poer lib
environments PP
road map agent feat Dem is this
um hold on I might have hardcoded that
somewhere is it top K Road points I
think this is supposed to be 64 now
invalid for
size
H this just not
save no this is a legitimate
eror let's see
so we've got unpack OBS
somewhere and then this is on line 36
demm oh Max controlled Vehicles is just
set wrong that's fine this is 32
work
nice so that is a
up and also it's probably going to be H
faster than 4X because we are now using
very very suboptimal batch
sizes so let's fix
that so 32x
16 um normally my rule of thumb is 4096
batch size but we're going to go a
little
more yeah 512 is definitely too low so
let's go to
32 let's see if this is faster it should
be
10K that's 10K real
throughput
and uh can we do
12K it's a little bit faster and 128
this is normally where I cap out is I do
4096 batch size which is what this
is and we'll double it one more time
just to
see
okay this one is pretty this is probably
a bit much it's slightly faster but
that's a lot of data so we'll leave it
at 128
reasonable now of course you know as
soon as this en is on GPU itself this
whole thing will Skyrocket
do we have a reply on
here
see
nope I think Eugene City doesn't think
it's 12.2 let me double
check I'm pretty sure
whoops what's the window key to like
restore all your tabs I hate that it
does that like who thought that that was
a good feature
yeah so Eugene says he does not think it
is a
Cuda 12
issue which would make sense I don't
think it should be either so really the
two things at the moment are Madrona and
whether we have decent metrics so I
don't know let's do do we want to just
track or run real
quick well we're not doing a 10 billion
step
run uh that not even
close 2 million
million so we can see if it actually
does anything over
B they say their Sim runs well over a
million
training definitely needs to be
faster training definitely needs to be
faster okay so here steps per
second and we get mean reward per
episode which looks like it
increases I think vehicle collision
should go down
stable we can throw a carb sweep at this
thing which is going to be the
plan oh yeah it goes
up it goes
though goal achieved isn't either
so we'll see what their train curves
look
like any replies on
I mean there are lots of things that we
can change here
though the main thing is just this is
not a
usable steps per second this has to be
much
higher like 80% time in the end
no
um I'm trying to think what we can
do is there anything we can do to like
that I haven't thought of to get madona
working
oh I totally missed Pablo's message I'm
not anyone yeah okay I thought it was a
different Pablo no
worries I have way too many windows open
today because of all the DMS and
stuff
um I'm just trying not to miss like
slack
messages that might
be them fixing
stuff this is a nice set of Curves
though
reward goes up it looks like it might be
crashing
now ENT is good
though no we're good it was just a
temporary hiccup it looks
like
right yeah
so interesting that this goal achieve
metric doesn't go up but reward does I
don't want to read too much into this
before I uh I fix up all the settings
though for
sure we also probably want a data
density
metric we should probably add
um data
density let's go ahead and do that right
now
uh self.
controlled agent
mask she that is not what we want
sum.
item divided
by
num worlds divide by numb
objects so this is going to tell us how
much data we're actually uh we're
actually getting that is real data this
is an important metric
did this thing level out yeah I leveled
out we're good it's nice and
stable I assume vehicle collisions are
supposed to be going down and stuff
definitely there's also the K unique
scenes thing
I probably need to edit
that I mean really the thing I want to
do is I want to have Madrona
working I think why it wouldn't work on
GPU
like I have Cuda
12.1
oops I missed no I didn't miss
anything
um hm
did I like do anything
stupid is
there no attribute close okay let's fix
that as
well I forgot to do
that this will give us data
density
oops
close Okay so we have a full run though
basically of a GPU
drive and you can see this point at the
end this is the puffers like it does a
good estimate at the very end for you
controlled mask sum okay I typo
something controlled agent
mask. sum.
item and now we get data
density okay so this is very bad right
here this is 34% data density and
actually it's worse than that because
it's actually uh it's supposed to be
live agent map mask which is self. mask
do
mask. sum which is uh yeah like
this so it's probably worse than
point that is
rough
holy
jeez 10% dat density is like
unusable so if they actually have the
funny thing is if actually right now
even on CPU we can match their train
steps per second uh on GPU if we had
dense
data
um which they said that there would be a
way to do that
potentially um but for
now I think we can still get
substantially better if we just get the
darn M to run
faster um yeah cuz there's also a little
bit of misk bandwidth transfer and other
stuff that we got to
right I right now I think I like wrap it
in a cereal or
something config
profile oh no it's it's right here so
and
B we do need need to do ve back end here
don't
here and we'll come up with a cleaner
way of doing that later but can I do
this no attribute render
right have a do render method yeah it
does so I think RGB
array. render
or G be
QT okay they use P game for rendering
and it doesn't seem like they
have different back end
um I can try to get the QT back and
working
through no it's not going to work
through this it'll have to be through um
it'll have to be local when I render it
which is fine
so I can commit this stuff up and I can
probably get this rendering
let's commit all this
up and let's see if we can see some uh
some policies
demo
PCH
puffer uh we don't need
that
okay we do need to go up to uh the GPU
drive and and change change some
stuff
sour I need to change the consts to be
this needs to be 32 agent count and this
needs to be
64 64
points oh let me give them an let me
give them
they asked for a demo of
something let me give that to them this
is a nice trick that we have uh in
snake let me just make sure I have this
is the right file
snake
pointers
oh they say that the en internally
doesn't have to P
that's good they say that they don't
actually need to pad internally this
would give you a ton of speed
back we could just implement this
straight up they say
oh they actually gave me hold on they
have a
PR they says return to tensor
irrespective of the number of Agents or
number of Worlds is this what they say
this is num agents
RL they literally have a clean RL
version that's
cool uh and then this
is batch
size what is self. batch size n *
wait this is funny why do they have
async
reset where' this API come from this is
my puffer API isn't it
ah okay I one sec I got to finish these
messages up
well okay one second I got to do uh one
thing I'll be right back
right
so this is funny they say that this is
actually based on puffer clean RL
implementation which is funny um clean
our they say their end Works clean our
part
doesn't I can help with
that
so they say that they tried to run
puffer tank just by pulling it
am might just give him SSH access to the
box I'm using
that would be easiest this is kind of
cool though that they actually they did
this based on puffer
implementation it's cool to see people
starting to use it um yeah because they
have like the ASN kpi and stuff
here I'm trying to think how
they oh I actually see what they're
doing oh this is
easy yeah this is easy I'll have to do a
copy but I can do it I can literally
implement this for them it wouldn't be
hard only thing I can't fix on my own is
the cish stuff I like I don't know
what's wrong with the uh the engine but
basically if they get that portion
working
then I can have it be fast enough to run
sweeps do some basic testing there and
then I can do this port for
them as long as I'm not dealing with
like crazy CPU threading hell where I'm
just like sitting here doing nothing I'm
happy to like keep doing stuff on this
this is good cuz this is a nice
Sim always have them hop in stream and
cowork not everybody's comfortable doing
that they can uh I they're free to chat
from here on stream but
uh yeah
I can also just link them the stream
right yeah they
can I can also just link on the Stream
so right we were trying to do something
though before we got uh we got
distracted here
right let's see CU they they're going to
have to take a second to do that so
let's actually see if we have any
policies
trained
um GPU Drive oops I don't want to lose
that tab
enough and we'll see if we can run the
the
visualizer um
install
reinstall oh good I thought I'd
forgotten to unmute the mic
command GP you drive
mode back
native let's see what this
anything okay so this is the comp this
is compilation not working
working you can see
um I think I just broke this
installation right I might just want to
redo the
here I don't really have anything in
here that I need right
yeah
no don't need any of
thisp
drive we'll just redo the
setup uh correctly from the puffer Fork
of
cursive all right so that'll take a
second and then what we'll do is we'll
edit those constants we'll apply it
we'll sync that to the puffer Fork as
well we'll see whether they like the uh
the policy as well that I have well
we'll see see how well it does first I
guess usually people are horrified by
how simple I make the uh the RL policies
but uh if you just push more samples
through them it usually evens out or
I forgot how slow this is on my
local well whatever it'll it will uh
oh there it goes so we'll set this up
hopefully this will let us run and we
will uh be able to see whether the
policy is any good
here non vehicle collisions have a value
of
8.0 may be a bug in your
code I think that they just have a mean
so maybe we'll look at that while this
is finishing if it takes a second it's
probably going to finish as soon as I
say that
[Music]
baselines this is
algorithms s
sp3
and I think it's rappers or
callbacks yeah this
all that's fine so our stuff is fine
it's just it we probably want to Norm it
um otherwise it's going to be like not
comparable across different experiment
scales so we'll have to Norm that but
for now it is
fine
[Music]
and almost forgot to do the thing that I
wanted to
do which is source
and then once this is
built we should be able to run the
viz so things that need to be done right
for this to be
fast
um Cuda obviously I actually I don't
even think we technically would need
Cuda on the environment but it's it's
either going to be Cuda or figure out
how to thread the environment properly
like it can't be thrashing a ton of
small processes so I might still mess
with that to see if I can get their CP
mode to run fast
um something like that
maybe but in the meantime we'll just do
the GPU
mode I do think it's conceivable that uh
CPU mode ends up being
faster we'll see how fast their Sim
is because like if you're wasting if
you're going like a even if it's a
million steps per
second you're still wasting a decent
chunk of your GPU time it could be
offset by Cuda transfer and other things
but um I have found that to be the case
before maybe for this since the data is
so big it wouldn't be as big of a
deal kind of nice to have the data on
GPU already
train some LM to play Dota 2 or
Starcraft
okay built perfect
so let's see if this runs
right we have that annoying
bug a big
deal move build
flash stormgate came out basically
Starcraft
3 that's cool for RL purposes though
like unless you build the EnV thinking
this has got to be fast for AI is not
going to be fast for
kind of weird how that
happened
uh
happens what do I do in
um oh it's as
tensor instead of from numpy
nice what I got rid of the from numai
call didn't
I oh I did it on the wrong machine is
not the same box
does this
work hey look at that the pink cars are
neuron Nets I
think is that how it works
yeah pink cars are neural Nets and we as
we also have to get the uh the policy
that we just trained
right
so
Oops why don't we just grab a GPU Drive
policy oh we didn't get the policy cuz
the Run crashed at the very
end well it's okay we can train another
one really
fast uh we only need it looks
it probably we only need like a
million million steps or
whatever million steps worth of data is
1 million
steps
back uh we'll just do Dash Dash Track
like this
Baseline yeah why not um except it's
supposed to be train Baseline yeah this
good so that'll give us a run in a
minute or two few minutes I should
say oh yeah one minute still it's not
bad
any additional messages from the
creators
machine oh there they go They're
messaging
something cool so we'll have this in a
second with un not Norm
dumb but still may be
okay this is now
done so watch how cool this
is if I do Dash Das Baseline
here GPU
goes that looks different from before
doesn't
different
0.139 is the reward is that what was
does that what we see
here oh no because this is per episode
what is the
reward is reward not logged no we don't
log reward we only log uh these metrics
okay yeah you can see that they the
behavior is different but not
good it's the pink agents that are the
uh
why the green ones also fly off the map
like
H well we have stuff to fix let me pull
up tail scale I'm going to add a one of
the devs to my
cluster probably don't want to advertise
this too widely because we do have
limited comput we were also affected by
the Intel chip issue so we're going to
be down a couple of boxes for uh a
couple of weeks most
likely um but we do technically do
compute
sponsorships for cool open source stuff
in this bace has to be using puffer has
to be something that we think is like
fundamental and good for this base but
we do technically do
that maybe both green and pink um they
said that some of them are supposed to
be human
on invite external
copy invite
well box seven is sad so link key um the
plan on those boxes and you guys have to
tell me if you wanted me to send seven
and four but there's a mic there's an
update coming out from Intel in a few
weeks um that will or like a couple of
weeks they said that should help in
combination with tweaking some settings
on the CPU and stuff um what they said
they're going to do is they're going to
adjust the timings install the update
when it's out test the machine
extensively if if it works they'll ship
it back if it doesn't they'll swap the
CPU but you know they're trying to do
limited CPU swaps if they can cuz as you
can imagine they have like a huge wave
of of stuff over this um cuz like most
of their boxes are Intel and they have
everybody ring everything
so we can ship box seven back though for
sure it's just a matter of whether we
want to do four and seven cuz they're
going to be out for if I ship box 4
tomorrow then they're going to have to
hold it until the micro code update
comes out I think you'd rather have it
for an extra
week I do need to start buying some more
boxes though for sure because we're
getting to the point where now I have
usage for more as well um technically I
could buy them right
now but I kind of would prefer to buy
them off of revenue for the from the
company if I can so I'd like to start on
that
first hold out on
four
yeah okay
ask if yeah they said that they will
they'll throw the BIOS update on it when
that comes out but um like I'm not there
in person to do that update so I have
like I can't have them ship it back and
then do the update myself and can't do
it remotely
okay so we're about to get this uh this
guy
onto one of the boxes
yeah does it get you right into the
Container when you log
in yeah it does cool so he should be all
set up
we can get this
started
um so they have oh that's interesting
they say blue is human
replay and pink is policy controlled
is this actually downloading the policy
is the
question one data is saved locally oh no
I see now the files downloaded take
vaults
there I think these might both actually
be neuronet controlled then
I don't know why they always look like
this one is slow though why sometimes
seg vaults as well is this actually
loading
correctly probability
tensor oh I think that's
um yeah there's a there's a local update
I need to push
High
GPU and M
torch Source
constants
what this should be a fork
I forked it didn't
I I could have sworn I forked
I think I remember that it
was the only thing I did in here was I
added
these added these lines let's do
that by Jeep VI drive
and
uh
porch and 147
is e States
on
Z they're having difficulty logging in
let me
see
scale see if it sees that
uh I should
see
let's just fix this in the meantime
while they figure that out
so that was all we needed
here and I should now be able to run
this without seg bolts
linky are you there was that remember
that issue where it would log you into
the like your own tailet instead of the
instead of mine
[ __ ] make sure you're on the right
Network yeah
do not see them I see the I see the user
added I don't see the um the machine
though I can see that they have no
machines he's got um
yeah need to log into T and then use the
email link yeah
oh look at that ah I got it whoa whoa
whoa whoa it actually did it you see
that it did get it there it got there
the one time I just saw it do
works did this just make me a gift or
did it just break my
terminal Dr eval
GIF maybe I've got something
poer
[Music]
that I bet it's getting masked wrong cuz
it does it the first time
let's see if it works for
him I don't know why tail skill does
that where it's like so easy to log in
by
though drives better than I
do okay cool he's got access for
well great now we've got uh
we've got
their their Dev on the
box looking at
this which is
great this is the one thing I do not
know how to
fix I can technically start a little
hyper parameter sweep in the meantime
right might be a decent thing to do for
them uh no because they're going to be
messing with the compiled file
yeah that's
okay
um let's see what is up with the reward
and
such let's see what's up with the reward
actions well first of all these spaces
don't
match so I think they did something
different
One log first to 95 so yeah it should be
goal achieved should be
increasing and the fact that it isn't
means that it's probably not training
particularly really
well it's odd
odd am I doing the masking backwards or
something now how would the reward be
going
up that doesn't make any
sense my bet is on something with the
data being wrong though
rewards going up but none of the other
metrics are going
up maybe I can extract
something from one be here let me see
the
okay do I have a better run before that
with the
losses not this
one there was a f mil
run this
one no I don't know why there're
no loss
panels should be
losses I think it needs development
versions of
Cuda
oh oh
that's annoying they need the
development they say they need Cuda
Dev I would not I would not have thought
of that
yeah dang I got to update
the base container for this
let me see if the P torch base
containers are any good
4.8
GB and then
I want 12.1
right
12.5 how the heck do they how the heck
are they deprecating stuff so damn
I have to get a 12.2 base as well it
looks
support guess today's going to be in for
and devops day
they have
local Cuda 12.2
okay it's so weird that they only have
latest and then they go to unsupported
and like they immediately are
deprecating
months after the last
supported driver has gone end of
life it should be
fine 12.2
is this is what we want
so I guess we're going to just do this
inside of this box
huh why is the tag structure totally
different e
not sure about torch
versions Jee
so what we're going to do
here uh we're going to edit the the
docker
files to be the latest versions I don't
know what's happened like they've
changed all of
their oh they just changed their nameing
convention is
all yeah this is fine they just changed
their name in
conventions 12.1 D runtime Boon
this um we'll go right like this
here
boom okay we got the Debian front end we
got python
3.11 we got
I think this is out of date isn't it
hold
um back out
[Music]
1.0 get
fine is my mic picking up background
noise
it anything greater than
okay they say this they say that this
should work I'm going to trust them that
this will
work let's get Cuda
here right on
pip
run torch torch
Vision uh we don't want this one this is
12.4 we want
12.1 that was almost
bad
okay so this will be our new base
container image
is
base base
it's
username
slash yeah it should be
place Das
D
Bas okay so there we go
and I'm actually going to even put their
environment into the new container so
that it's like first class
support be easier for people to get
it's not that bad I think the second
stage build is the one that's always a
pain
so but it'll be
cashable and I and I think the cake
version works as
well so we don't have to deal with that
which is nice
very exciting world world of rebuilding
Docker
images people have been asking me to do
2.4 for a while
though I don't think there was does did
the Pokemon project need anything else
linky in the base containers
I think that guy just wanted a 2.4 I
know that they wanted um upgraded a
buntu but that's not going to happen
just yet
um nvidia's updated their new containers
but it's not going to happen until we
have um P torch with Cuda
12.5 uh then we can get upgraded
auntu as a
base and it's very likely that's going
to break a bunch of stuff and take some
time to fix
there going to be some breaking changes
as well when we get uh really recent
versions of python with some of the
older
environments like this is the year that
like a lot of people just straight up
move to language models and stop
maintaining stuff entirely
so most of us run bare medal except for
the
boxes boxes are there for a
reason the puffer tank containers are
very nice
you literally get an identical setup to
the boxes locally for
free any nice simple M you want to add
to puffer so I can get some practice
thinking of Tetris if no one is making
it
yet uh so Noah was doing breakout you
can do
Tetris um I think Tetris should be a
pretty easy M to make make right cuz
like you can do pixel observations but
also the state is technically a
grid linky the containers don't take
your RAM like that they're very thin
um Tetris Tetris would be cool I think
Tetris would be on the easier side as
well there's some other M's that we
definitely want but are going to be
harder to do with a grid like
um I imagine that like some of thear RM
right are going to be harder to
do even something as basic as pong is
going to be slightly annoying to do on a
grid like I know how to do pong on a
grid uh it's just slightly
annoying requires a little
discretization Tech Tetris would
definitely be cool
though let me think if there's anything
wrong with
that no I think should be pretty
straightforward I have Tetris working in
Atari as well like the Atari
Tetris grid you mean for rendering or
OBS well you can render whatever you
want but the observations like if you
don't want to have you want to have an
image option probably but you also want
to have uh an option to do
why use a grid for pong what state would
you
suggest you could technically come up
with some like featurization of where
the ball is and where the paddle is I
guess that would probably also work just
fine
most of these environments you can
probably do that as long as you're not
wanting to train on multiple at the same
time some normalized relative position
yeah you could do
that it'd be cool if we could come up
with some like Universal way of
representing all the Atari Ms that
doesn't require us to render to pixels
but what compatibility will break
updating to higher
python older versions of gym older
environments that don't have packages
exported like proen I think has annoying
stuff yeah a lot of things all right
well this is our Docker build
torch was for
Cuda y we got
Cuda this image is deprecated and
scheduled for
deletion dude why are they deprecating
stuff that's like this like they're
deprecating stuff way too quickly I
don't know what they're
[Music]
doing username name
let me go figure this out cool will give
it a go yeah Tetris is good Tetris is
nice because it has a really obvious
grid representation for the state
right so you don't have to think very
much thinking is hard I advise I advise
uh avoiding it whenever you can
[Music]
look at that isn't that
docker so that's stage one of the build
once this is done we'll start on stage
two and then stage three is quick after
that
well that'll get us uh a proper version
of torch at
least and
uh looks like it will probably increase
the image size a bit with the dev stuff
for Cuda but it's
okay eventually I'd like to get a more
minimal image but it's just so hard with
all the M's we
support it's like the one thing I had to
compromise on like I can get everything
else but I can't get the image size to
be more
reasonable it's not bad if you have a
gigabit like gigabit Ethernet or
whatever but it's pretty bad
otherwise speed will be much faster than
this
poor guys doing front
end I don't feel too bad because
cursor's writing all the code for him
I probably should have gotten a gigabit
up as well for the cluster don't you
think I can probably start this though
um I can start the next build while I'm
deps this is the second stage of the
build it goes from base
1.0 NE vim and Vim plug go there I would
like to put it above this but I know
that that portion is slow so what we're
going to do instead is
we're going to clone their repo my Fork
of the repo so I have easier control
over
and and then we do their uh their
install stuff
and this is I need to get the python
flag here
what's the python flag that I should
probably do for this
old and this has to be fine Python 3
okay we'll just not do that for
now I think this does
it and we'll just do
um I need to go find the the path
where's the other python
uh where' this
go okay so you make. J
file so and CD dot dot and pip install
Dash e dot that's good
not
sure oh
hello I see you're in the live stream
now I'm just renaming this thing for now
because I'm going to have to redo this
every time I build the container um also
I don't know if you guys have looked at
this but um it's kind of annoying to get
the GPU Drive environment working out
outside of the uh the directory where
it's installed you need a SIM
link so like I
have if you look in uh puffer
lib I've got this Pi GPU Drive
Link
GPU
G so I think we got to do CD dot
dot High GPU Drive
is that the right
syntax let's
see path to folder to be
linked which is okay I have it backwards
no wait the folder to be linked is p
yeah I have it
right okay so this looks
good so then this is oh what is this
called is this puffer depths I check our
Docker
Hub docker
unfamiliar with
manually well the thing is that pip
should do it I use them I use the PIP
install and it doesn't link
it are you sure that poetry does that
for you because um in the example
scripts you have you have some stuff
that has to manually change dur in order
to get the paths right so that was why I
had to in this
case docker
here why is the why can't I see puffer a
on here it should be here right
Jesus that's so screwy how you can't see
your own stuff on dockerhub
it's like all these like it's all the
way at the bottom of the page underneath
all like the verified whatevers
tags
no there should be multiple things under
here
cool oh this is not going to work wait
I'm dumb
yeah poetry has a yeah so I don't use
cond of VM because it's redundant inside
of a docker right having virtualization
plus Docker is just like nutty so I do
um everything is managed everything is
bare but it's inside of
containers that workflow has been
ridiculously effective for me with uh
with
puffer because if something goes wrong I
don't have to rebuild the whole
environment right it's literally 5
Seconds to Nuke a container and remake a
new
one not to mention it gives me a
consistent Dev environment locally and
on server
oh there it goes okay this is pushed so
now I can actually build this because
it'll pull from the correct
uh it should pull from online correctly
I would
hope I will be right back going to use
the restroom uh this will build and then
we'll upload this and the last stage
build is really
[Music]
thank you linky
um almost done with this and if this
works we'll have uh out of the box
puffer integration with GPU Drive you'll
just be able to grab the container and
you have it all set
up precompiled and
everything why Docker is really
nice well there it goes that's
now one of the benefits of being the
author of the container is that I get to
put my own personal config in
there and you can change it if you like
but that's the
default good question is going to
be why training is getting stuck it's
possible I'm doing the masking wrong
it's possible the scale is just too
small possible we need better
hypers lots of things
architecture I uh I replaced the default
Network which is kind of clunky with a
simpler version of it it's got the same
three like three encoder structure
carbs yeah we're going to run
carbs how's GPU Drive coming along we
hit a bunch of infra stuff but um I
think we're good now we'll see whether
Madrona Works once this uh this compiles
we are rebuilding all the puffer tanks
and we're kind of pushing a silent
puffer tank update which should be
non-breaking should
be um
it will contain Pi torch uh 2.4 instead
of 2.4
Dev hold
on failed to
slash ah I didn't CD into it
that's fine it's
cashed it's cashed um we use yeah you
use 2.4 already but you use a Dev Branch
by default in the containers so this is
just going to be the full release 2.4
Cuda goes from 12.1 uh to
12.2 and that's about it are you running
it on GPU with puffer yes I've been
forced to run it on GPU well I'm
attempting to run it on GPU and I've
been forced to because we could not find
a way to disable multi-threading in um
in madona uh it it's possible that we
could be
faster it's
possible um that will depend on some
other
factors but for now I got sick of that I
like I spent all day on that yesterday I
couldn't get it to work so uh now
instead we're going to get it to work
with the GPU we're going to focus on
just getting hyper pram sweeps getting
you know the day two integration so this
doesn't drag on any longer and uh people
already will have like you know within
48 Hours a very nice way of using this
project uh with puffer with all of our
nice monitoring tools with
hyperparameter sweeps and you know all
the other things that are difficult to
get with the um the current sp3
Baseline not to mention we get lstm
support as well which they don't
have we get an lstm
policy car should probably be able to
remember stuff
all
right that's actually compiling now
we'll see if uh I mean every time this
fails this whole St stage has to redo so
hopefully I got it right this time
Triton
3 uh I did not manually change
Triton if it comes with Triton 3 now it
comes with Triton 3 now I do not know
about Triton okay perfect it's actually
built um that's incredibly nice
push and this is a smaller this is a
smaller it looks like so perfect that'll
work its way
up and then what's the last stage right
now
file this is fine
right
yeah annoys me that I don't have the
puffer fish prompt on my stream it just
shows up as a undefined character works
on most terminals Windows one doesn't I
don't know
why windows
I seriously seriously hope that this
makes madron
work there's not any way to test it like
you easily
right I think we'll just have to hope it
works um
yeah if this doesn't work I don't know
what will
though oh the other thing is we got the
Cuda development
build apparently that was uh the thing
it wasn't even that we needed 12.2
necessarily though maybe we did it was
that we probably needed the de Vel mment
build I'm hoping that's the issue I have
no idea what else it would possibly be
because we'll have everything at this
point
yeah this is the thing I'm also worried
about is it's basically outputting slop
and then being trained on
um how long would it take us to run a
decent sweep of this should also just
open their paper
right that would be a useful thing to
do while we wait for
yeah
linky
so over a
million agent steps per second yeah 512
worlds
linear
scaling up to 128 worlds interesting
end to end
speed 10 million
steps and they say that they actually
get um one7 is 10
million so they looks like they have to
train for like 10 million steps so we
need to do a few million step runs
okay possibly lower we'll
see okay this is now
done uh now what we have to do is
do and this is now puer
seconds ah shoot there was a thing here
wasn't there
okay good I was just making sure I
didn't have stuff on here that I was
worried about
pretty fast
build it should just have to run uh the
PIP
install and then we'll upload this and
we'll be done
puffer's got a lot of dependencies
that's got to be fixed I think this is
the common option that installs
literally everything so that's
fine looks fascinating I wish I
understood it me too man I wish I
understood what was going on right now
too
um what we're attempting to do at the
moment is we're attempting to adjust
some of our infrastructure so that we
can run uh this GPU driving simulator
which is really cool just came out
yesterday so here's this GPU driving
Sim um we're trying to run this properly
but it's not launching in GPU mode so
I'm currently trying to fix that and
trying to make it easy to use in puffer
lib and then I'm going to try to train
some neural networks to drive these cars
really well and we're going to use some
automated algorithms to train like a 100
different neural networks differently to
drive cars and we're going to see which
one does the
best and it's all going to happen super
fast and automatically with very very
simple code
yeah this is
um this is like some of what I normally
do is I add like existing Ms I also
build my own M I do a lot of like high
perf Sim uh simulation engineering
mostly more for game M but we're
branching out on there for
sure um other few other things as well
mostly just trying to make reinforcement
learning fast and easy I do multi-agent
stuff I do like massively multi-agent
stuff very
often uh we currently have like a
miniature version of DOTA that I'm
building that runs at like a million
FPS yeah lots of stuff in this are lots
of stuff in this area but every so often
stuff gets kind of slow and we end up
just being like waiting around on Docker
builds and stuff so couple slow
days pretty much once we have this done
though and once we have a few other
things around puffer fixed like all the
experimental setup for everything is
just about to the point where we can
automate it
this will be the last layer of the
build so after this will be set
what about their
paper
so all clock seconds 10,000 seconds is
still too
slow 10,000 seconds is still way too
slow oh no they don't take 10,000
seconds they take like I mean this is
still like um 20 20 minutes or whatever
it's still too
slow going make this faster
interesting they got hyper
parameters 30
mins do you know what it's 30 minutes
for like is that I can't tell cuz it
says 10 tasks is it 30 minutes for 10
million steps or like dapne told me it
was 50,000 train steps per second after
you account correctly for padding is
that right
if so and if the N is actually like it's
over a million steps per second of dense
data as well right is what the
environment can
produce because if we can get over a
million steps per second of dense data
out of the environment like um the
standard training in puffer lib like for
our newer environments we train at
500,000 to a million steps per second
pretty
standard so goal would be an order of
magnitude faster than what you have now
now some agents won't reach yeah that's
fine but like you have numbers on here
that are like
um and it's goal reaching like I don't
know what the task is for this as well
cuz like I don't know what subset of the
environments this is with like there are
a lot of different environments some of
which are easy and some of which are
hard
right
um like I'd really like to see what
happens if we do like a big hyper
parameter sweep on this
and we get some really nice hyper
parameters and then we run it for like a
billion
steps or 10 billion
steps if the en if the environment is
fast enough to produce the
data it would be
nice hey look at
this CPU with puffer lib
no we got decent frame we got decent
perf out of it it was I didn't spend
that long on it that's
funny oh you did site the thing why
thank
you just the types of observations you
can use you can control
radius OBS lidar and view
cone
cool are there like hard tasks that are
unsolved in this or is it like yeah we
made this really fast and then uh we
trained it and it reaches all the goals
like is there anything unsolved here or
is it now like a matter of let's make it
like super super fast and stable and all
of that
n VCC is still not
found some agents cannot reach their
goals
ever I
see well we'll still get some cool stuff
going out of this um I'm a little bit
concerned that we still don't have
nvcc we installed the dev build as
well this has got to not be the right
container right
wait no we have 12.2 but where did a GPU
drive
go that doesn't make any sense we
installed GPU Drive didn't
directory try our best to remove such
agents
mhm I'm going to have to rebuild this
thing aren't I maybe this is good enough
for now
though uh
update your
drivers you realize that this is a
Debian server
right yeah I know five yeah you realize
this is a Debian server
to get 535 I already had to do a bunch
of annoying stuff with
experimental I'm not I'm not going to
remotely brick all these machines by
screwing with the base system
installs base package maintenances for
when I'm there in
person it's it's incredibly incredibly
easy um like I've managed to like
actually brick the machines to the point
where I've had to like I've had to like
recover outside of boot so yeah you got
to be
careful it's uh it's not as trivial as
you would think I actually somewhat
regret Debian for that reason I don't
think it's a huge difference but um
it's moderately annoying that they're
not that quick to add the
drivers but I don't
Colo
well they're not collocated they're just
in a garage that I'm not in at the
moment right they're not in a facility
here I I don't understand what the hell
just happened with this
can you oh I missed this message from
before um can you
find yeah one second
found
nah h
I have Cuda 12 oddly I also have
Cuda not
installed well we'll see um if this is
enough or if I have the wrong base I'd
hope
not so this is
fixed uh GPU
[Music]
drive I'm going to get this to install
we're going to try it um
and uh after that I'm going to take like
5 minutes to go make myself a
shake
and then I will continue with this I
usually continue I work on this until
like 7 7:30 usually
change I thought I pushed minor
fixes
annoying can I actually just do that
real quick
I don't understand why it is is there no
make make clean
again at least I know I'm getting the
right
file okay so this is
CPU match is what we had
well not compiled was Cuda support damn
it
um so no
nvcc with the
base here let me push the
disheartening should be able to build
with one of nvidia's images this is one
of nvidia's images here I'll show you
the I'll show you the base you can tell
me if it looks reasonable if not we'll
work on this tomorrow but uh yeah that's
rough it's very rough
um especially considering I'll have to
redo the whole three stage build um but
here this is the the docker file for you
it's in here you can look at this whole
repo if you want so I'll paste the repo
and then I'll show you the immediate
Docker file see if you see anything if
not we'll just call it
um where's the base I mean I can still
run a sweep of some type
maybe but yeah so it's NVC R iio Nvidia
Cuda no hold
on I just committed this how is this the
same it's not possible
container how is this
possible I saw 12.2 in the container
coner what happened with the
base oh I have Cuda 121 not Cuda 122 how
the hell did I do
that well
[ __ ] I I remember I put this link in it
must have not gotten
synced but I have Cuda 122 in the
container yeah
12.2 that's weird
right but there's no nvcc so it must
actually be the
runtime well I will fix
that I will probably have to rebuild
that um that's fine I will do that
that's my mess up so I'll do that uh
we'll see if that fixes it hopefully
and if not then we'll figure out what we
do I know it's late in uh New York yeah
I'll uh yeah just Cuda things I'll try
to post in the slack I'll try to
remember to post in the slack if I get
it working um I got like another
probably two three hours on this so
hopefully I get it working by then um
and I can start running like hyper pram
sweeps and stuff that would be really
awesome anyways thanks for dropping by
and thanks for all the support
uh I will see you tomorrow and as for
the rest of the folks here I'm still
going to keep working on this I just
need to go take a quick second to make
myself a shake before I pass out because
I forgot lunch so I'll be back in like
five minutes and then what we'll do is
we'll rebuild all of this stuff actually
I should rebuild it before I go because
then it will be built by the time I get
back so let's do that
Docker well this looks like it actually
could very well just be my screw up
yeah this is what I got as it got 12.2 I
remember copying this in I don't know
how it didn't
save right
well yeah it's it doesn't have it
locally so it must be new well my my bad
I guess
um I'll let this build I'm going to go
grab a quick Shake I'll be back with
that in a
right perfect good timing let doing the
last stage of the building right
now of course now we got to do the other
ones but I'm hoping this will be enough
I'm hoping I should also test this one
because uh it's possible that we get
version compatibility [ __ ] and we
also want to make sure we actually have
nvcc why do I not see myself on this
stream list
it should show me it's live
right that's
with carbs did you ever run into unable
to generate R
yep yep that happens
um do you
have are your bounds
impossible like do you have like Min
greater than Max or something
on specific variables that's pretty
least this is funny I have not refreshed
this tab in a long time 714 to
759 that's
nice dang we're actually
like how long till we pass sample
Factory
778 like a week that's
crazy that is
I'm hoping that this means we get a wand
B carbs integration
there we
go
so oh I
also hold I want to make sure I'm not
blowing off Discord
messages
depending I might
be yeah I might be once this uh
colleague of mine gets home I might jump
off stream early to chat with him but
we'll see let's we'll keep on the docker
builds for now deps CU I can also do
this on a call this is like brain dead
work
um I need to upload this don't I
boot I forgot about
that I don't think I can even do
anything until I upload it because it'll
I don't know if it'll grab the right
version
W so this will be
pushed see if we have have any cool
stuff in the puffer
Discord that's another good use of time
yep breakout
en I already fixed that
one for
okay that's
good oh I just saw your stuff re search
center was outside the bounds yep did
your nested parameters yaml config work
with wanb sweep configs uh yes it did um
it was a little tricky the the dev
branch has any files Now train is an
invalid parameter um probably needs to
do the nesting correctly you need to do
like parameters of train of parameters
of
thing can we do RL stuff with images
with this engine like agents that learn
to draw
mest if there is an RL environment where
that is a thing then yes um we have I
mean we have Atari and proin and a
bajillion other image-based environments
right we have support for those and it's
faster than pretty much anywhere else
that you would use them it's just slow
compared to the ultra high performance
environments that we're doing work with
these
days we have Atari training at like 30
to 40,000 steps per second
typically which is like 10x what you get
out of the box with s
cereal it's kind of cool that they're
actually doing like one to one with the
atarian
cool thing about um streaming all this
stuff is like when people write custom
environments and they need help getting
stuff working and making it fast I can
just do it on
stream offer is valid for anybody like
making Huffer Ms for uh like the open
source
side so that's basically anyone minus
company doing their own proprietary
stuff
there will be support contracts
available for that
though service is more than contracts
account is this done yet
still
no
n I am hopeful at least that this will
work once we finish
this it's okay if we have a slow day
once in a while like
this it's only Wednesday so I've got
Thursday Friday to get this stuff set up
I might even stream uh Saturday as well
we'll see this week is going to be a
little different I am going to be most
likely off Monday and even maybe Tuesday
of next week I've got some stuff to
do more on that in a
bit this is also the lowest layer to
build and
push but hey this will be
um the official uh puffer container
substantially upgraded at least we no
longer have this kind of janky torch
branch and we'll also have the Cuda Dev
Tools in here so more stuff should
compile easily we also get nvcc which is
nice I was originally I did the runtime
just to save space but probably that
wasn't a smart idea for exactly this
reason I wonder is there anything else
we can look at in the
meantime probably I should have been
like doing something with these Atari m
i find the multitasking very difficult
though um we can probably go make
ourselves some like Optimal configs in
the meantime
right why not
right what are we up to today
more stuff with GPU Drive um I'm
currently rebuilding all the docker
layer so I'm just realizing that I
should probably do something on the side
while I am doing
this so why don't we just go get some
optimal Atari configs just while we're
waiting this should not be very hard
long I'll put this up on my other
monitor so I can see um when it's done
in the mean time let's go get uh let's
go get some hyper
parameters cuz we actually ran a whole
bunch of good sweep
I think this is the first one
maybe this is
breakout well we probably have optimal
hyper parameters for pong already by
default right so maybe we will start
here
some of these things probably need to be
inherited or whatever which is obnoxious
but
yeah
o it's kind of gross actually
do I want to maybe just like copy the
pertinent stuff for now and then I'll
figure it out
later let's do that otherwise I'm going
to drive myself nuts
um episode
return this one here looks good
so this one
here which gets a return
of like 60 by the end okay probably
one frame skip
four repat action probability
zero batch size 32k
BPT Horizon is
eight clip coefficient is a little
coefficient little
different G
Lambda be
similar we're actually going to be a ble
to like plot the optimal hyper
parameters and stuff for these which is
going to be
nice we're going to be able to do so
much good analysis come to think of
it oh yeah there's so much good
experimental stuff we can do now I'm
realizing we're so
close can you imagine like we're going
to be able to basically like we'll take
these seven environments right we'll do
this the these tuned versions we'll make
sure that we get like good uh
highquality runs out of these and then
we'll see how much better uh like the
average hyperparameter set is among
these versus
um like using individual sets
really we should have a way to like
upload these prams to any files or
something
but I'll take
time okay so this is
breakout prams
done still pushing the
image here's beam
Rider oh and these is uh these are
stable runs as well aren't
they so
like oh this is crazy look at this one
there's one that like does really well
and then crashes a
bunch that's
funny do you have a run for monz
zumas I don't have a run for monz zumas
yet we can do that though
I think this is the best one right here
like best consistent
run oh wait this is episode length we
didn't do
return here let's try
this is this more stable oh yeah that's
way more stable look at
that so the best run we see is right
here
let's see the optimal
prams seven minutes for this train run
by the
way it's all it
I think that what's going to happen with
monz zumas is it's like it's going to
flail around for a bit and maybe
eventually learn like the first screen
and that's about it and then if you want
to be like your classic reinforcement
learning researcher you can spend three
months of your life or more actually I'm
sure people have spent much more than
that like just tuning the heck out of it
trying to just force this dumb thing to
work on Montas which it has no business
doing
well Fair Point link key but in that
case I am at the very least letting you
script some
stuff to get around
things at least a few things
I'm trying to think if Pokemon versus
monaz zumas
like I don't
know the thing is like you actually have
deep you actually have better access to
the like the state and stuff so you can
actually like reward shape and stuff
whereas monz zumas they're just using
the score and expecting it to do
something
so I don't know what that's supposed to
do
but these are also some crazy hyper
parameters still doing the least amount
of scripting yeah you're doing
well you're doing very well
okay so that's the these are prams now
that we have for beam
Rider oh perfect we just finished this
so this is now
pushed
um
[Music]
Docker puffer Das
depths uper Dash deps
proper
depths GPU Drive is here and we wanted
to
work dur sler
tank
so I think this is
cool so this is now
building event are huge help
yeah I put this
Discord oops I might be jumping off
stream here hold
on let me
that that's pretty
solid I don't know like some of these
other ones are probably better though
it's hard to say I think we'll use this
one for now but uh I think that like
some of these Merit much longer sweeps
frankly should just like cue each
environment up on a puffer box just
monopolize
the whole puffer cluster with freaking
seven Atari environments for a
day we'll pick a day and just do giant
sweep and we'll just solve Atari in a
day it'll be
great solving Atari in a day with Po and
hyperparameter
tuning the funny thing is even if I did
that and even if it worked there would
be a ton of salty researchers saying
that now you have to use sticky actions
even though you know they break
everything and oh you have to use the
same set of hyper parameters for all the
environments even though that literally
makes no
sense you can't
win but you can you might not be able to
win but you absolutely can make some
really good
agents absolutely can do
that cubert
that would actually be so funny if I
just like made a baseline where it's
like hey we train each environment for a
day and we beat soda or whatever and I
just submit that paper to see to a
conference just to see what
happens cuz that's totally doable like
we'll be able to simulate enough
samples if I just like check how much uh
wall clock training time other
algorithms use I'm pretty sure that we
would just beat them because we'd get 10
times the amount training data just
because of the speed difference
why was that wait was that g Lambda
real where the heck was that g Lambda
from there's no way that this did I just
paste this without realizing it there's
no way that this was the G Lambda I
think I screwed
up this is why I need to have this
process automated for sure
if I didn't screw up that's going to be
even scarier
though holy that's
ridiculous I have no idea why that's the
G Lambda
freaking
0.14 was
bizarre some reason it's very stable
what's the interpretation of Lambda
equals zero
again it's different from discount equal
to one right isn't it or just count
equal zero whatever
2 C coefficient is already
done entropy
coefficient uh does it have a higher
entropy no this actually this is okay
this is the entropy and
then G Lambda is8 this is a much more
reasonable value uh for J Lambda why is
this already
done cubert we're in the right
file gamma is
.94 it's a very reasonable
value it's kind of funny though when you
just do these full hyperparameter tuning
runs and it's just like whatever the
hyper parameter parameter run tells you
is correct is correct and like you don't
rely on your bad into about how things
are supposed to
helps yeah but linky that doesn't I got
to go look at the formulas that doesn't
tell me
anything I know the interpretation at
um there's separate interpretations at
zero and
one I know the interpretation of the
discounting factor I haven't looked at
the J Lambda in a
be less
sensitive uh than the discount
Factor oh split
yeah I didn't see the message my
bad value function clip
cool I'm a little suspicious about this
Frame skip
parameter oh I did I not sweep
it no I did I swept it if it's always
four for all M's though I'm a little
suspicious that it seems like sketchy
that it would just always be four for
all M's is the
optimal gamma is just you're probably
right J
I've math is boring
and then like the researchers will tell
you yeah you're going to want to set
like G Lambda like above like below 0.9
makes no sense and you do the hyper
parameter sweep and it sets it to
0.14 look at this Space Invaders run
this is
crazy look at that
I guess this is not a particularly good
score though for Space Invaders right
but it's a very nice curve 5 minute
train
run explain variance does not look
good oh wait I forgot we were building
Docker images gamma is Discount yep
failed to
solve cannot CD to perer tank jiu
Drive
Space
Invaders all Fram skip four is very odd
to me up to make sure I'm actually
sweeping that Pam
well sounds like a bad
Linker this clip coefficient is very
stable at like 02
something I wonder how sensitive it is
though to
that entropy is actually nice and stable
too
I think there's like a little bit of a
range for that one G lambda's
69 uh gamma's
.99 99 for Space
Invaders I wouldn't think Space Invaders
would be a particularly long Horizon
game as you just shoot the things
right Max grad Norm
and
um mini badge
size it' be cool if we could find a way
to do like all of the m at the same time
or something I don't
know uh let's see M's workers time
steps
seven
oops 7.5
mil do
EPO 4 I don't know why they have so many
update Epoch as well they like they do
so many updates on stale
data but I'm no longer attached to any
of my preconceived notions about RL
anymore I just run the experiments and
they simply tell
you CU it's become a apparent to me that
nobody understands how the hell any of
this stuff
works I no failed to solve again what I
do cannot open
shared Google test ad wait Google test
ad tests
huh Nvidia
tool Invidia Cuda
toolkit is that what I need is NVIDIA
Cuda toolkit
this 2018 let's get something more
recent
what the
hell where's um
had can't grap in a container that
doesn't exist
linky so
there I mean I guess the easiest thing
to do is going to just be to like
comment all
this and then I'm just going to boot
into this I'll boot into the container
and I'll figure out what I fix it on the
container
uh oh that's not linky that's that guy
what's
up you can run hold on let me make
sure you can run LD
config yeah I'm going to build a partial
that's what I'm
uh it's right there in the normal
spot it's literally right there in the
normal
spot so I guess what we do is we run
the hold
on what we do is we run the
normal
okay get clone
Yol
well we're going to do
something necessary Sim link should be
there
I've got like I had this error I
remember in like 2013 or something drove
like 16year old me
insane because I couldn't figure out
what the hell was wrong with the bloody
drivers that like this stuff still ex
like this is still around what the
10 years ago it took 24 to 48 hours to
get invidious it
up see make has bugs
maybe we're about to find
well that doesn't seem like it broke
anything right
this
works they
yeah now
what was
the how's it erroring
I don't like to install py test py test
is
fult says it passed I think it just
doesn't have cleanup good cleanup right
so why is it not working when I do this
um otherwise
right because I
have let me see do I have
uh I'm going to have lost this
is it running CPU or GPU it should be
doing GPU but like I'm doing the same
build setup so there's no way it should
be failing in the docker
build there's so much cool RL stuff to
be done man we're so close to just
having like the whole ecosystem
fixed you should see the Atari
sweeps they're sweet
are you using multi-stage yep puffer
tank is a three-stage build if by
multi-stage you mean three Docker files
then
yes yeah we just replace the entire
Tesla stack with like 100 lines of
puffer lib that'd be
everywhere the real black pill though on
um autonomous like vehicles for delivery
and stuff is that it's a regulation
problem if we just allowed like
autonomous drones we would have
basically free delivery by now cuz
there's no navigation problem they just
go up they go to the destination they go
down way to build artifacts in a
container and then copy what you need
from that container to the One You're
Building um I'm using three Docker files
to do that
build okay so here's what happens it
gets
there and then it says GP Drive build
test my
tests and it fails
here so it actually it says
linking linking my tests and then it
fails Dum Dums putting traffic cones on
Whos yeah you know what they need to do
in the Whos they need to add like they
need to install one of those big like
white gloved cartoon hands you know on
like a boxing stick or whatever so that
the car can just like slap those people
that'd be
You're Building test code I don't know
why I'm building test
code did I do anything
weird no I
don't so it gets to the m cmake
right this is c-j or what is it make DJ
um how is it possible that this is
different when I do it
[Applause]
built
Target dash dash head is it headless is
that why is that because it detects it's
building headless or
something I don't see anything else that
would be
different if you build it manually test
is always
see
make well what do I do with it like
there's something wonky here isn't
there so the thing it says is
that the Cuda lib Cuda is not
opened but the weird thing is this build
isn't
even is there anything in this build
that would cause you to need to
refresh is there a way I can like
refresh like the terminal or
whatever like what's the equivalent of
refreshing the terminal cuz I do install
a bunch of packages and stuff maybe it
just needs like a terminal
refresh you can treat it as a new
terminal spawn for each run
recursive makeer PCD
build make
DJ
fails because I can't find a Cuda
Library where
Library okay well you know we're not
we're not victims here we uh we have uh
we have some agency right we can
where's the
tests this
here get
out get out
we just disable their bloody
tests
right now it'll
reclone it'll grab the new version it
will not run the test
boom we'll see if it break somewhere
else was not breaking on the test
go okay um here's what's going to happen
folks I've got a call uh I'm going to go
chat with a colleague
um I'm going to uh finish these builds
tonight I if this does not work I don't
know we'll debug tomorrow but I'm hoping
it works um and if so you know I'll get
like an initial okay steps per second
maybe whatever or something like that
and then we'll pick this back up
tomorrow we'll try to finish GPU drive
and then over like the next several days
it's going to be this it's going to be
finishing the Atari sweeps it's going to
be getting better MOBA sweeps Lots and
lots of like experimental hyper pram
type work all right so um yeah thanks
for tuning in all the stuff that I'm
working on here is immediately and
always uh free and open source you can
get all of this stuff right here in
puffer
lib this is all my work I work on this
full-time so if you'd like to support my
work for free just star the repository
it helps me out a ton I also post all
the stuff on X I'll post that as well
this is just my research stuff it's not
like a bunch of politics or [ __ ] so
there you go thanks everyone and uh